one okay welcome back to the morning
toast
we are freaking out you guys because we
are sitting down
virtually with someone we discuss here
all the time on the morning at least
once a week
at least when we recap beverly hills
please welcome to the show dorit
kemsley hi jaree
hi guys how are you we are good amazing
we have to preface this interview by
telling you that we
stand so hard your looks this season are
just giving breathing life into the
season and it's an already good season
so we just have so much to talk to you
about but before we do we just need to
say thank you for everything that you're
bringing
like physically and mentally spiritually
um to the season thank you so much
wow you have made my friday okay
we literally just i have so many
questions here we just watched this
week's episode
and to be honest like we don't know if
the way that we feel about you know the
current situation
is how most people are feeling but i
really feel like you are taking the
really mature route on this whole brandy
denny's drama like
really not concerned with whether or not
it's true but just like should we be
talking about this
right yeah yeah and we see next week
season finale snuck up on us so fast you
did
um this is where denise kind of cuts
with the filming
you hear uh you say that she blocked you
are you and we thought you and denise
had a beautiful friendship especially in
italy like we were really
impressed with with how you guys just
kind of weathered the storm um where do
you guys stand now
denise and i are friends i mean i don't
i don't think that that's a secret
um great multiple times and you know i'm
happy to say denise and i have a great
friendship
uh she's somebody that i connected with
very quickly when i met her for the
first time
two years ago when i was going through a
hard time she really lent herself
in in such a soft kind
way and you know i don't forget those
things and we really bonded and
i think she's very funny and i think
she's um
she's sweet and kind and caring and all
of those things
and you know i don't know brandi well in
fact i met her and
inside of the first 30 seconds you know
she
insulted me and you know she and i it
just
if you're if there is a story which
you know i have to believe either my
friend or somebody i don't know
um anything about and is isn't
hasn't been very nice i mean it's clear
i'm going to be on denise's side
you know right and then i think that
there's a level
um you know where you just you don't go
you know and what's the purpose why are
you doing this what are you doing this
for
you know what you totally can understand
and it does feel like on beverly hills
you guys do stay above
that level most of the time everyone has
things that they don't want to share on
the show but that
grace wasn't awarded to denise in this
instant and that's what seems unfair
right well i mean listen there's the
the flip side to that and the truth is
we are on a reality show where we
are showing our entire lives and there's
been plenty of things that maybe
we don't get to pick and choose what we
want to show what we don't want to show
we just
don't because you put yourself out there
and there's the curiosity
um of the audience and the producers
jobs and the
networks jobs and you know the cast job
um is really to show the real
the reality of the situation and
everything the good bad the ugly so
that's the
alternative argument and i do understand
that um
i think as far as women go and us women
it's
something you know none of the women in
our group
in our core group brought this
information to the table they didn't
the information was brought from brandy
to the group
um and then of course there is this
argument well
what happens then it's out there the
information wasn't delivered to me had
it been delivered to me
i wouldn't have done it the way it was
done
but i have a different relationship with
denise you know yeah
done it very differently and i certainly
would have made it wouldn't have made it
very public and i certainly wouldn't
have talked about some of those
sorted details at the baby shower when
you found out that brandy was going to
be in attendance
did you shoot denise a text and let her
know or she genuinely just decided not
to show up and it was like perfect
timing for her
she actually had facetimed me before the
baby shower had started before i knew
brandy was coming
that she was sick and she couldn't come
okay so
i don't know if she had any wind of it
or or what but she
um you know she did facetime me telling
me she couldn't come because she was
sick
and then showing up at the end of the
baby shower
i think another reason why we've really
connected with this season is that glam
is like a topic of conversation at an
all-time high
and aside from the actual looks it was
actually part of the storyline some of
the fighting you know when you showed up
late
to malibu which i was totally on your
side like i just thought kyle was being
so unreasonable
um can you talk a little bit about like
what does your day look like when you
film i know on the trip i'm sure it was
back to back with glam and then daytime
in the night time
but what is an actual day in the life of
a housewife when you're putting these
looks together what is that what does
that look like
so for me i mean i like to it depends on
my mood
obviously whatever we're doing but i
love to put looks together i love to
play
uh it's a space that i really enjoy you
know the fashion space and the glam
space um i love it it's who i am i enjoy
doing it
um so i choose an outfit i put together
the look
and then i've got a great team my
justine marjon who's my
uh hairstylist and very dear friend my
best friends we've been working together
for
a number of years and you know i trust
her she knows me so well
so once i've put together the look i'll
collaborate with her and decide how i
want to do my hair
um and she just you know she kills it
she
kills it and time and time again she's
so next level
uh it's fantastic for me because i get
to work with you know my friends
and we get yeah and when you have a
similar vision and you understand one
another
you know each other so well you can
really have a great time at it and i
think that that's what you're seeing the
byproduct of that
um so that's the process for me i choose
an outfit i put together sometimes the
night before
if we're traveling then obviously i'll
pack a couple of days before and put
together a few different looks
and and then other times when i don't
have the time
and i know i'm shooting and keep in mind
i've got two little ones and businesses
and so
life is always very crazy and very busy
um
i could just literally be grabbing
something
as i'm going you know or throwing
something together after the fact
you know if i if i do have my hair and
makeup done and it's low key then it's
i'm going for a low-key outfit you know
kind of more comfort
yeah what has been your favorite look
that you've worn this season
we'll tell you ours it's so hard to hear
yours because it's
really hard there's so many that i love
mine is actually not that obvious you
know i don't think mine is
the same way i think the lunch in italy
the fendi one
no no lunch with kyle in italy when you
wore that big black like scrunchie
around your hair it was just so
understated and so
elegant and just so different i know i
loved that
i felt the same and it wasn't kind of
what i was going for again
the outfit really spoke to the way i
wore my hair and my makeup
yes because you almost looked like you
were going to a funeral and some could
say
that lunch might have been the funeral
of your and kyle's friendship some could
say
what was yours no i think we're talking
about the same one because she's wearing
the fendi tights and the fendi boots
and the trench and the scrunchie oh
maybe yeah and it was just it was like
it's not the most obvious one but
it was so like delicate and low-key and
just and also like fendi and roma it was
perfection it was perfection
i agree and i also wearing those italian
designers
in italy in rome i mean for me i just
felt like it was paying respect
yeah i was having a love affair with
versace last year
i mean i just thought everything she did
you know i was drawn to
and so i think my favorite and it's
really hard because there's so many
that i love um it's hard to pick
favorite it's like children
i can't favorite of my children i love
them both you know
it wouldn't be right i really really
love the versace suit
and that was a lot of fun because it
kind of came together it was
brought to me um i've got a wardrobe
stylist that i've worked with for many
years she's also a dear friend
she's in new york city and she'll she'll
send me some things i mean we've known
each other a long time it's great when
people really know you because i don't
have time to shop these days so
you know things a lot of things will get
sent and then i kind of pick and choose
and when i was putting it together and i
i had all of these versace accessories
laid out
i was actually putting it together and i
was pinning things all over
and then i put on the belt and i i
couldn't decide which belt
i liked so i kind of had them both up
and then i was like wait a minute i got
like them together
so then i stacked the belts wow i mean i
i
yeah i stuck to the belts and then i
ended up putting even hair pins
on the jacket wow so
for me that was such a fun look i had a
necklace wrapped around my
my my wrist um and i don't like outfits
like that i like where
when it kind of you know i there's a
little bit of me that
you know there's a ud there's an
originality um
there was an outfit i wore a prada set
it was to denise's
infamous pony barbecue
with the pony well that i actually cut
the prada shirt
because i wanted it to be level with the
pen and it was a high went
high waist pant i didn't want to tuck it
in because it had a cute little belt
around the pant
and it bunched too much so i actually
cut it and then with
that piece i sewed a hair scarf and then
put it in
here so that that look came together and
i love
things like that i mean honorable
mention to the attico dress you wore to
kyle's event that was just sickening
show stopping
give birth to it throw it in a blender
mix it up reference it
not reference it it was just [ __ ]
brilliant like and i can imagine how
much time that takes and we want as
viewers we want to let you know like we
appreciate it so much
it elevates the show to a completely
different level which is
i think what really sets it apart from
other franchises it's like these looks
it's like
it's milan fashion it's like a magazine
it's something that we like maybe used
to get from other mediums that now with
so many people watching reality tv
you guys are real like they kind of what
we used to get from maybe a show like
gossip girls yes
girls in the city yes like those looks
that are really curated and have like a
theme and
a an idea to them you guys are serving
up on beverly hills and it does not go
unnoticed no it does not look bad i'm so
glad too because
that's the that's the when i get teased
for it i say to myself i mean
you're not going to change me that is
that is what i like
doing so it's so lame it's so lame when
people tease others like for
being creative yeah it's like an art
exactly or for planning it's like why
would you teach someone for wanting to
look nice
too can't relate for their job like that
they're showing up to because it's not
just you're going to a workout event
in for teddy like yes it it's that but
it's also like you're recording
like a show that so many people watch
and it's going to be out there people
watching it for years and years and
years and like that look
is gonna have legs exactly also i was
wearing beverly beach
leggings you don't have to defend
yourself dory you look sickening
the beach down you look sickening gag
worthy walked in i'm like yes i'm glad
she's late and she's not even lame
because she
said she was only coming for half the
[ __ ] day
i love you and also it's so important
that you take those pictures
those pictures are so important like so
important
i mean that's the whole thing is that
why waste such a good look i want to see
it
and i know other people want to see it
you know i'm i'm literally making that
time
and that takes a matter of minutes this
is not like
let's just book a half a day for a photo
shoot it's not like that it's
no all the photos should you snap a few
pictures you know
we don't do it we all do that yes i know
exactly and that's that's the gram isn't
it
it's the gram can you tell us a little
bit about the reunion you guys filmed it
remotely
was denise there yes love it i'm so glad
i think she deserves a moment to explain
herself
me too i was so glad she she was there
and and in truth
she had said to me leading up um that
there was
no way she wasn't going to be there so i
expected her to be there
oh good a lot of there's always a lot of
chatter in the press and
you know it's it's hard because when
conversations happen in the press
or the press takes it to the next level
and then
we kind of operate with our hands behind
our back because you can't answer every
single thing you know
but but i'm glad she was there uh the
reunion all the virtually
was epic it was really incredible it's
definitely one you want to tune into
excellent um yeah and that that book was
a lot of fun putting together
i mean so you have to have a lot of fun
i i
really loved loved the dress and i loved
the hair
um that i did and as far as the actual
content in the reunion
definitely worth tuning into it's really
good do you think denise is going to
return
i don't see why she wouldn't
i don't see why she wouldn't i mean i
say that
she's friends with me she's friends with
garcelle um
you know the only reason why someone
wouldn't return is if they're
either not friends with anyone in the
group anymore
or if they just um you know
they're just not wanted i suppose and i
don't think it's either of those
that it's not neither of those but i
don't know i mean that believe me if you
ask me
you can ask me all of those questions
but it's the powers that be that
that actually right denise that make
those decisions
so yeah nice well speaking of the powers
that be something that denise said this
season she said bravo bravo bravo which
we now know is something that you say
when
you don't want something to air is that
something that's like used often like do
have other people said that over the
course of your time on the show and like
we didn't
ever get to see it no no no not
in fact it's kind of the first time i've
ever seen it
okay so it's really not a tool
to not get footage aired you know which
is why bravo deliberately
put it in because imagine that you guys
imagine if we could all
arbitrarily choose what we wanted to air
and not air
i mean producing a show which we're not
producers on
right no i think that she had heard it
um some of the og's kyle lisa vanderpump
they had said that
back in the day when they wanted to
touch up their makeup they would say it
while they were
you know putting powder on their nose
but if it's anything juicy oh no it's
never
removed from the show that's just that's
so interesting
one other breaking the fourth wall
question because there's this rumor
going around that um
that kyle and teddy filmed the scene
with
brandy and kyle after you guys got back
from rome so
goes to say that they got the
information about denise
off camera off camera and then they
decided to bring it up in rome and then
film a scene where
they're being told as if it's for the
first time
i didn't i didn't hear that i mean i was
told in rome and it was
told to me by the girls that they had
filmed with brandy and this had happened
okay okay so yeah i have another
question for you totally unrelated but
it
i just have like i've been we've been
waiting for this like you're just gonna
have to sit here for two hours sorry
um you know it wasn't too it wasn't too
long ago that you were the new girl and
i think
in your first season it was tough for
you like not ever you didn't jive with
everyone everyone didn't jive with you
um and now that you are kind of like a
resident
cast mate and new girls come on like
what is your
like how do you decide to introduce
yourself do you go out of your way to be
nice to new girls because i know that
you and garcelle have a really great
friendship
and i feel like you and sutton get along
really well like your love of shopping
are you doing that intentionally just
because like you were the new girl once
and it wasn't as easy for you okay
so and i i i really like you guys so i'm
i feel like you know heart open on my
hands you know hint of my heart heart on
my sleeve whatever they that the word is
here's the thing i've always been that
kind of girl that when i meet people
i if i kind of like everybody
you know and until you give me a reason
not to i'm warm and nice and kind and i
enjoy meeting people
and that's the way i always was and then
i
applied that in the show um didn't
always work
and i kind of realized i mean when i had
sort of met teddy for the first time you
know i thought that we were friendly and
then things were good and then
you know she's texting me and i i felt
like i kind of
put my heart into her and then when i
watched the show back
her first season it was just like all of
the like
bashing and talking and it was like so
shocking to me so it was like this whole
new world i had to become
um adapted to and so therefore i kind of
decided after that okay well
i'm going to approach it where i'm going
to be myself and be nice and kind
if there's any kind of signs or reasons
for me to go slowly i'll i'll do it so
i think that the answer the long-winded
answer that you're looking for is that
garcelle when i first met her it was
just an easy connection
she was so fun and it was just i our
personalities connected we had a great
time
and i really liked her from the
beginning sutton on the other hand
she things can come out of her mouth
without thinking she's quirky
i've gotten to know son so i can tell
you she's so lovely i really enjoy her
we have become friends but in the
beginning i was like
trying to figure her out you know trying
to understand because i didn't really
know
you know is she gonna like me am i gonna
like her
is she gonna say something that's like
so you know
extraordinary and shocking and she does
yes she does i guess that's kind of the
beauty of the show which i think is why
she's such a good
addition to the show i agree yeah she
brings something different
yeah i think like at first i i wasn't
sure what her role was going to be
um but i actually think she fits in
really well i think you guys all the
group
i think for the i think we speak on
behalf of the fans and we were ready to
get lisa banner pump out like from
literally five years ago like we have
been riding this train we are the
conductors of the train
get her off of the show like i just
think she's so toxic and manipulative
and like we were really believers in
that
and i think a lot of people were like
well where does the show go from here
she was on it from the beginning she was
an integral part of every storyline you
know sniper from the side
but now that we're here i feel like you
really get to see
a lot more character development from
you guys um there's more
like real genuine friendships like i'm
sure i mean i think a lot of you guys
hang out off camera
we do and that's beautiful real genuine
friendships and it
even shooting you know filming or
i would say filming how best to say it
um
you know it feels like it's it's just
there's a freedom to it there's like
something that's sort of lifted and i
think that's why you're seeing
um a lot more develops
development developments in friendships
and
characters and so on and i think that
lisa was
you know a very important part to the
show for a very long time
and she had a very big fan base she
still has a very big fan base
and you know it was her decision to
leave and i think that um
you know maybe it was the best decision
for her
for everybody it just it felt different
after she had left there was definitely
something
that lifted or shifted and i think a
lightness
yeah everybody across the board kind of
felt it
yeah well it's nice to watch it uh all
play out one final question
i have one two okay so one each who is
your favorite designer
another tuffy i just i don't have one
favorite
it's funny because um you know obviously
i'm a fashion lover
so i'm always tracking the fashion and
it depends i mean i think dior's doing
some incredible things
but you know two seasons ago was gucci
and
you know i've got decide i've got
designers that are not
um you know known designers that i
really like and try i could not give you
one i couldn't even give you 10 probably
okay fair what do you think your monthly
budget for glam and wardrobe is when
you're filming
i mean that's hard and i'm not sure i'd
actually
mention that okay but that actually
wasn't my last question my last question
was how was your house
love i love the house i love that really
great
do you have the party at your house next
week yes
oh is it a housewarming it is a
housewarming
and my husband and i developed a
non-alcoholic champagne called the stews
that uh we launched at the party we've
got it's fabulous
like 15 foot champagne bottle in our
pool
so you'll see yeah the house is
beautiful and you'll get a chance to see
it really
um for the first time this season like
kind of more done
oh that's exciting fabulous well to read
we absolutely
loved having you here i know your time
is so precious thank you for being here
thank you for all you do
and just saving the show and you're just
everything of the sort
keep doing you never apologize for who
you are bring the looks
bring the hair bring the attitude we are
here and we are living for it
i love it love you so amazing
thank you guys have a good one